it's going to happen now the sunday
surprise coming out of week five the
2020 season chris here's the trivia
question for you
derek carr became the first raiders
quarterback with two touchdown passes of
50 or more yards in the same game since
who
raiders quarterback oh raiders
quarterback
is an x raiders quarterback all right uh
raiders quarterback with two touchdown
passes of 50 or more yards okay you have
seven seconds i'm gonna say i'm gonna go
with like an obscure one here and go
kerry collins
[Music]
but there's a connection right because
he played for the giants at one point
and so did jeff hostetler oh
the guy
yeah i guess i could have given you a
hint like you once put shaving cream in
any shape yeah that would have been too
easy but yeah hostile that year 93 they
they threw the ball down the field they
really did i remember that and of course
i think the raiders went to the playoffs
that year as well um but uh yeah so that
was 96 okay i was thinking of another
year but
yeah okay i got that that i haven't
heard hosteler's name in a while he's
playing good that year he didn't have
any shaving shaving cream in his cleats
he was good to go
i i really was hoping you would get it
right because i hate to do this to you
because
you're responsible for my awareness of
what chase claypool could do and yeah
i've let millions of others in on the
secret and it's not a secret anymore but
it was a surprise yesterday
four touchdowns from chase claypool and
a fifth one that was called back so uh
give me chase clay pool sorry chris i
had to take that's all right that's it's
worth taking uh he he's all yours don't
worry all good there's plenty to go
around i mean you've heard of aaron
donald right right you've heard of him
he had uh four sacks yesterday but the
surprise was the other guy who had three
sacks no not leonard floyd not michael
brockers how about troy reader three
sacks by the rams we didn't get to
discuss that game at all uh in depth
because of alex smith we kind of went
into all that but man that rams defense
once again i mean aaron donald we know
he's a superstar reader was all over the
field too making plays and and sean
mcvay jared goff i mean it just was uh
poetry in motion yesterday they just
whooped the washington team from the
get-go and uh yeah mcveigh seemed like
he cracked the code on the matrix on
that one pretty quickly and they were up
and down the field
well and mcveigh another guy with a
history in that organization who's not
going to come out and say anything like
your guy kyle did last year frankly i
prefer it when
somebody's willing to stir it up a
little bit like kyle did last year
mcveigh's always going to take the high
road but he was there he knows he knows
what it's like or what it was like it's
better now but i'm sure that the fact
that it's better now
uh didn't take away any of the steam
that he may have had to go back there
and take care of business the way that
he did all right next one for me
and uh this was a surprise and it was
the the subject of the trivia question
derek carr got to give him credit yeah
throwing the ball down the field
something we have been waiting for him
to do something john gruden has been
begging for him to do and maybe it took
a game against a patrick mahomes right
hey patrick mahomes throws it down the
field i better throw it down the field
what's the worst that can happen oh well
it's an interception i mean you throw
the ball 50 yards down the field it's
like it's like a punt
so just just do it just let it fly and
see what happens and uh if he if if he
can keep doing it
man you know they get their bye this
week then they have tampa bay on sunday
night football so he gets another
measuring stick game against a great
quarterback he goes from the greatest
currently in the game to the greatest of
all time maybe that'll continue to draw
out of derek carr what john gruden has
been hoping for for the last two and a
half years yeah maybe
certainly you know they are a different
team when rugs is on the field and you
saw they could run the football we know
that with that old line and everything
there to where how can you not be
excited about what the raiders have done
i mean they you know gruden mayok
they've turned around the team it's
close i'm not saying they're there yet
but they got a lot of the vital pieces
already there in place really the only
thing i look at on their team and go
just needs to get better is their d-line
they just got to get some real legit
like difference makers up there
and uh watch out for the raiders all
right i mean we're on a surprise i mean
this is a crap surprise but it was a
surprise all right and that's the 49ers
the 49ers defense i think that's
specifically what was shocking to me
about that game yesterday the san
francisco 49ers
ryan fitzpatrick went up and down the
field on them big plays they attacked
their corners who are banged up there's
a lot of backups playing there uh for
the 49ers and they just had their way
all day long and just not used to seeing
the 49ers defense play like that i mean
miami ran the ball threw the ball for
big plays
controlled the clock did anything they
really wanted to and i can't really
remember the last time i saw the 49ers
defense on their heels like i did
yesterday
it was just amazing to see them lose in
that fashion and
you know from time to time what i'll say
when i see a team lose like that
that it's it's almost it's almost
disqualifying like they should just be
taken off the board of contenders to
lose like that at home right to a team
like the dolphins you're disqualified
you're done no matter what you do the
rest of the way and they're gonna have
to earn it if they get their playoff
spot with that seven game stretch coming
up that we talked about earlier but that
was a stunner and we got to get the
dolphins some credit they brian flores
and company went in there and took
advantage of a team that was wounded and
they didn't give them a chance at any
time to get in the game all right
alexander madison
that was a surprise to me although not
really because we saw glimpses of what
he could do last year right he had a
higher yards per carry average than
dalvin cook and you know the vikings
ultimately paid dalvin cook i think they
really didn't want to because they knew
we could always turn to alexander
madison and here they are 112 yards for
madison on 20 carries 5.6 yards per
carry that average dragged down
just a bit by his final carry of the
night the one that uh went nowhere when
he didn't see that tiny little that just
that little sliver yeah what did gail
sayers always say
six inches a day like i thought was it
whatever it was yeah uh i i think that's
what the vikings gave alexander madison
last night if he just noticed that you
know there was enough room to to land a
jumbo jet off to his right but but he
still had a good game and it tells me
the vikings offense will be fine if the
mri that's going to be performed on
dalvin cook's groin injury today ends up
knocking him out at all they'll be fine
with alexander madison yeah i i hear you
he's a good player no doubt i'm actually
stuck with running backs in my brain
here i mean i'm down to two guys really
i'm like you know mike davis and
carolina but i think i'm gonna go to
todd gurley in atlanta because we saw
todd gurley yesterday that we haven't
seen in a while you know we really did
121 yards rushing
broke a few runs that you saw well okay
gurley still got some speed yeah he
might not go 70 and 80 yards to the
house like he did in the old days but
he's still got enough to like oh he sees
a seam or he can bounce around the edge
and turn the corner and rip off a 30 20
yard gain whatever it is so that was fun
to see it was encouraging i felt good
for him because i felt like we haven't
seen that from todd gurley in really
about two years ever since the super
bowl year for the rams uh but that was
that was a pleasant surprise yesterday
yeah and it's weird because it comes on
the same day that they
got rid of of everybody
and uh
and and you know what is it going to
mean for these guys all going forward
all right uh last one for me
and uh you know we've already talked
about the browns but but how can we not
say that what the browns did yesterday
um so wait so you did mine around four
points uh never mind no okay all right
good just one
i'm sorry i was saying you're stressed
out
it's one two three four let me tell you
what happened let me tell you what
happened was third down along again all
four things tuning in now i don't have
jaundice it's just the filter um but and
mar our good friend marion atlanta the
eagles fan she thinks i look green
yellow i'm trying to replicate the
seahawks jerseys from last night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports